okay thank you very much uh for everyone
who attends uh the
call today so the title of the talk is
advances in crispr screens gene
modulation and single cell analysis
provide new insight
so let's get going
before i begin i just have to read this
out so the life science business of
merck kga darmstadt germany operates as
military sigma in the us and canada but
elsewhere we are known as merck
screening strategies have really evolved
over the past couple of decades from
swinging blindly in the dark with random
mutagenesis
growing into more educated approaches in
the age of genome sequencing with orfs
and rnai libraries
until we arrive in this golden era of
crispr where we have high precision high
efficiency targeting for controlled
manipulation of the genome
now
when it comes to
our place in genome editing technology
or our history we really are leading the
way in the genome editing field and we
did not come into the field in the
crispr era we started over 15 years ago
with targetron which was a prokaryotic
system and then through a licensing
agreement with sangdom or biosciences we
were the first commercial company to
offer a targeted genome engineering tool
known as zinc finger nucleases
back in 2007. along the way we've also
had a number of firsts with our
scientists collaborating
uh with sangamo
um to generate xenophon gene knockout
rats and also we were the first to show
that oligos could be used as a donut
template for integration
then we move on to the crispr era and
once again not only were we the first to
market with crispr-based products but we
filed our first patent very early on in
now we already have a very strong
relationship with the broad institute
but we have continued to work through
collaborations with innovative and
world-renowned institutes and companies
to bring groundbreaking tools to our
customers with the examples here being
the first to market send a whole genome
arrayed lentivirus human and mouse
libraries in collaboration with the
welcome trial sanger institute in the uk
the 10x genomics compatible custom pools
for single cell analysis via
collaboration with 10x genomics and then
earlier this year the whole genome
crispri libraries in collaboration with
ucsf
in addition we've also continued to
invest heavily in our own r d and some
of you may have heard a talk given by my
colleague jennifer bennett earlier this
week actually last week on our new pure
edit rnp reagents for translational
research that will be coming out early
next year
i mentioned ip we also maintain a very
strong footprint in the crispr iep
landscape with several more patents
recently awarded taking us to 40 at
present with no doubt more to come
these are covering a number of different
technologies crispr integration and then
a couple of technologies where we're
trying to access parts of the genome
which are have been previously
inaccessible with crispr chrome and
proxy crispr
and preparedness is more of a
specificity technology and then we have
normal novel gene modification systems
as well
so now let's move to the crux of the
presentation which is screening using
crispr now there are primary primarily
two types of screens that you can do
pull screens which combine thousands of
shr and ao guide rnas in a single tube
and are raid screens which consist of
thousands of unique welds of individual
shr nail guide rnas
pull screens are most widely used and
pretty straightforward up front but
require much more of a time investment
on the back end due to data
deconvolution validation because
obviously you have these guides in a
pool
a raid screens require a more
substantial upfront investment of labor
because obviously you've got one gene
sorry one guide for well which means
you've got multiple
plates there but they do yield a broader
diversity of data points and much less
back-end effort because as you know
which guy doesn't each well the data is
already collected
but the general workflow for these two
types of crispr screens is pretty much
the same
okay so with that in mind we have
libraries suitable for both options as
you can see here so we have arrayed and
called options across all the main
technologies being crispr knockout
crisper a and crisper eye
as i said we also have shrna as well as
offs but that's not the purpose of the
call others right the presentation today
and these libraries allow customers to
start at the top of the funnel as you
can see on the right with genome-wide
libraries to integrate the whole genome
moving on to off-the-shelf or customized
to your needs subpools
for narrowing down the hits and finally
individual clones for validation which
again can be either off the shelf or
customized to whatever specification you
require
i will call out here that we've launched
an expanded list of knockouts crisper
eye and crisper a pulled libraries to
what we've traditionally offered in the
last week actually
and i will highlight these as we go
through the presentation
okay so crispr as a genome engineering
tool can be used to achieve a wide array
of genetic modifications
gene knockout is probably the most
common option shown here but today we're
going to focus in more detail on
epigenetic regulation using crispr
activation and inhibition while still
touching on crispr knockout
really the take-home message here is
that we can harness the power of crispr
technology to enable virtually any
genomic manipulation desired
when people talk about uses of crispr
and crispr-mediated gene editing they're
usually talking about nuclease-based
creation of double-stranded breaks
when using nucleus-based crispr
technologies we're really relying on the
endogenous dna repair mechanisms to
achieve the desired modification
the outcomes are achieved through either
nhej
or hdr
but and although there are some tools
and strategies that can shift this
balance a little it's not really your
choice which mechanism the cell uses to
repair the double stranded brake
and it predominantly uses an atj often
resulting in a loss of function mutation
caused by a frameshifting insertion or
division
however the full extent of crispr's
utility extends beyond just targeted
cutting of dna
nucleate independent applications of
crispr provide all of the targeting
specificity but for cargo delivery
the most use of which is for gene
regulation
so let's start with crispr knockout
before we delve into gene regulation
in terms of array screening merck
partnered with the welcome trustanger
institute to develop the highest quality
arrayed crispr screening format
this library spans the whole genome of
human and mouse so that would be
targeting more than seventeen thousand
and more than twenty thousand genes
respectively
the library and individual clones are
pre-made and are available off the shelf
so you can get what you need as soon as
you need it
there are two guide rnas but gene
available where the team focused on
minimizing redundancy and focused on the
best guide rnas rather than more guide
rnas
it's available in glycerol stock or in
lentiviral format and if you go for the
individual clones these are also
available in dna format
you have the option of the whole genome
your own favorite set of genes or
choosing from one of our multiple focus
panels and more on that on the next
slide
the guide rna vector contains both pure
selection marker as well as a blue
fluorescent protein or bfp as
highlighted in the image on the right
in terms of the guide rna design we use
specially designed bioinformatic
algorithms to maximize gene knockout by
targeting the first half of the protein
coding sequence of the gene
but obviously avoiding the first 90 base
pairs of coding sequence where
alternative start sites are known to
occur
we also strive to optimize targeting by
avoiding smps and only accepting guide
rna designs that have at least two base
pair mismatch at other
genomic sites
there is a joint paper that was written
by researchers at the sangha and at
sigma aldrich which used the sangha
library and is referenced here
functional knockout was demonstrated in
cas9 expressing aml cells by stably
integrating guide rnas against seven gpi
genes before treatment with a
fluorescently labeled aerolysin toxin in
a so-called flare assay now loss of
function of the gpi genes results in
loss of gpi anchored cell surface
proteins
and since flare binds into cells
expressing the gpi anchor proteins
loss of the protein should mean a loss
of fair activity which can then be
detected by flow as you can see on the
right in two separate aml cells
sorry two different aml cell lines with
two different guides per gene as you can
see in red and green the percentage of
flare negative cells demonstrates that
the sanger guide rnas were able to
generate significant functional knockout
now i've already mentioned to start off
with that you can choose either whole
library whole genome library or from one
of our multiple curated evidence-based
focus panels
so now we spent
some time looking at the genes that make
our panels in a number of different
available databases and then we made two
versions of our panels
the expanded discovery is much larger
and contains a gene that's a that appear
in at least one of the databases whereas
the core essential is more focused
requiring the genes to be in two or more
databases
and of course we can increase trillions
even further for custom panels that you
may want
that was the array screening on the pull
screen side we have a number of options
for you now traditionally we've offered
the option of
the gecko version 2 and a sigma pull
which is an extension of the gecko
version 2 with more guides and separated
into eight pools rather than two
we now in the last week have expanded to
include new off-the-shelf pooled
offerings that include novel and
state-of-the-art algorithms for guide
rna selection
and efficiency from the primary
literature and of course as i've already
mentioned we can
also make custom versions of all of our
libraries using any of the available
vectors from these whole genomes
i have on here the convolution but i
will speak about our deconvolution
service in a later yeah sorry later in
the talk
okay so now let's move to the nucleus
independent applications of crispr
these applications use a nuclear dead
version of cas9 called
dcas9
which harbors point mutations that
inactivate only the dna cleavage
function
crispr can be used to activate or
inhibit transcription by delivering
affected domains to attract or repel the
transcriptional machinery
while crispr a technology has evolved
over time into more creative and
powerful activators crispr eye has
remained relatively unchanged due to its
high inhibitory
efficiency so let's um let's begin with
uh with uh with
with uh with the strategy the targeting
strategy so when it comes to targeting
strategy and guide designed crispr a and
chris are comparatively much simpler
than crisper cutting when you design a
guide for knockouts you require
gene-specific design right targeted
exons must be shared between all
isoforms to avoid potential compensation
the target site must be early enough in
the gene to ensure complete loss of
function as i mentioned before because
you don't want to be so early that you
may
allow usage of an alternative or cryptic
start codon
activation inhibition on the other hand
have universal design rules targeting
bases surrounding the transcriptional
start site meaning one guide
can capture all splice variants from a
single tss because of this specificity
you can have high confidence in guides
and with these systems you can worry
much less as a result about off target
activity due to nuclea's independence
and tight activity windows
let's start with crispr activation then
the synergistic activation mediator or
sam was created by feng zhang's lab at
the broad institute and is a powerful
three-part crispr based transcriptional
activator complex
at its core is the dcas9vp6
fusion protein that forms the basic
synthetic transcriptional factor
it complexes with a guide rna which has
been modified to include two rna aptamas
and then these aptamers recruit
additional transcriptional co-activators
via binding of a fused ms2 viral code
protein
the final complex is capable of driving
robust activation of gene expression at
the target locus
although a number of crispr activators
exist including a different one of their
own
george church's lab published a nice
comparison paper showing that the crispr
sam system is the superior activator
this result was then validated in ipscs
by the met scorpion lab at the welcome
trustsanger institute
and therefore this is the crispr a
technology that we chose to develop and
offer
as i mentioned before christopher sam is
an effective transcriptional activator
this qrt pcr amplification curve shows
that guides to oct4 increase expression
above baseline by 9 to 10 cycles which
i'm sure you'll agree is a lot
because crispr-sam drives activation
of gene expression from endogenous loci
the level of activation will be
dependent on the baseline activity of
the locus
for example hex cells are differentiated
and express opt for at low level so you
can see a strong increase with crispr
sam whereas in ipscs on the other hand
activation of oct4 would not appear
significant because that locus is
already fully active and oct4 is already
highly transcribed
in this graph you can see ace two
expression activation hexels
these numbers might seem unrealistically
high because a2 is just not expressed in
these cells so big delta delta cp
will give very high fall change numbers
it also shows that although some genes
can benefit from combinatorial effects
of multiple guides not all genes show or
need these cumulative effects
and this system is also highly effective
in other eukaryotic and mammalian
systems like mice seen here via the
neural 2g activation
although crispr sam activation is
effective in plasmid form for transient
transfections the original backbone
produces poorly packaged lentiviral
particles on the left is a p24 elisa
count showing total viral particles
and packaged functional viruses on the
right and if you can see it's many
orders of magnitude lower which is
obviously bad
so we modified the vector backbone to
improve viral production and we also
optimize the system for improved
transcriptional efficiency including
putting a g in the final sorry in the
first position of the guide rna that was
missing in the original design
now modified lengthy plasmids produce
substantially higher levels of
functional virus
without this improvement for this sample
here to transduce a hundred thousand
cells in a 12 well plate for example
you'd have to add 40 ml of mostly empty
virus per well to get appropriate
transduction with our lenti particles at
this titer with our modifications you'd
only need about 10 microliters of virus
so down from 40 ml to 10 microliters
our functional type of sam now meets the
efficiency we believe is required for
whole genome screening with a pool's
library of guides
so why would you add crispr a or crispr
a screening to your toolbox crispr a is
complementary to existing loss of
function technologies as each enriches
for different sets of genes responsible
for the same phenotypes however unlike
loss of function technologies crispr a
is fairly unique for gain of function
screening
to achieve a loss of function with a
crispr nucleate the cas9 needs to create
a double-stranded break that happens to
be repaired in such a way
that an indel either causes a frame
shift or disrupts a functional domain in
every copy of the gene as we've
discussed
when performing a knockout screen in
cancer cell lane you often have to worry
about the ability to completely knock
out high copy number genes due to
polyploidy
these aren't concerns for activation
screens because only one copy of the
target gene is needed the targeting
complex just needs to buy into one copy
and recruit the co-activators
with dcas9 based systems there's also no
risk of genome instability from
double-stranded breaks because
unlike nuclei there is no cutting
and by activating transcription of the
endogenous locus
instead of the trans instead of
transgenic over expression of undefined
ice form
crispr a allows the cell to dictate
isoform expression and splice variation
in a more physiologically relevant
manner in contrast to transgenic
over-expression screens with say orfs
to recur we offer custom pools and
off-the-shelf whole genome antiviral
libraries for human and mouse in this
system
as part of our crispr sam offering
now to validate our libraries we perform
the breath inhibitor screen also
described in feng zhang's original
sandpaper we transduced crispr samsable
a375
brass mutant melanoma cells with one of
our sand guide library subpools
and we select it with
plx-4720 or the murafinib to enrich for
cells that were resistance to drug
mediated growth inhibition
our screen produced egfr as a top hit
which recapitulates the data showing
etfr as a driver of resistance to this
drug
to ensure that crisp array is
functioning normally in your cell line
we recommend using our rfx4 positive
control
rfx4 expression is generally not
detected in most cell lines reported and
is amenable to strong activation with
crispr sam
this particular guide target is
conserved across human mouse and wrap
and is a suitable positive control for
cell lines derived from each of them
now i mentioned earlier that we have
some new pool libraries but we didn't
just stop at those new pool libraries
for knockout that i mentioned before
these two activation libraries for both
mouse and human represent the next set
of evolved crispr activation libraries
using data driven discovery to optimize
guide rna placement
and selection to deliver highly
efficient compact libraries for maximum
results in your screening experiments
again this is from the primary
literature and i do have a slide at the
end mentioning the publications
so while gainer function crispr
screening is obvious in its
complementary relationship to
traditional crispr knockout screening
crispr eye actually offers unique
complementarity to both systems
crispr interference mediates the
inhibition of gene expression by
competing with the transcriptional
machinery for promoter binding
thus inhibiting transcription initiation
additionally the crab or [ __ ]
associated box effector domain
recruits epigenetic modifier proteins to
further repress local transcription
as part of our continuing efforts to
bring you the best tools available we
now offer the improved crispr eye guide
design and guide scaffold through an
agreement with ucsf and we also recently
partnered with 10x genomics to develop
compatible crispr products to enhance
your screening capabilities
now crispr eye technology has been
described in great detail by the labs of
luke gilbert at ucsf and jonathan
wiseman who is now
at mit
this figure shows the optimal targeting
window for crisper eye here in orange
much like crispr a it operates within a
fairly specific targeting window
surrounding the transcriptional start
site
now their guide design strategy for
crispr eye has been updated over the
years and it has improved substantially
based on optimized guide algorithms and
machine learning and most recently
incorporates nucleosome positioning data
to improve genomic accessibility
here they show how the predicted guide
activity has improved with each
iteration of guide design optimization
and the arrow shows you that we are
using the crisper eye version 2.1 in our
libraries
now we compare the top guides between
this and a competitor algorithm to
determine which guide design yields the
best knockdown and we focused on targets
identified as hard to repress
sure our guide design algorithm results
in optimum knock now
the weizmann lab didn't stop there so
they also conducted a series of guide
rna sequence modifications to improve
transcription and guide stability
they identified the putative rna
polymerase 3 termination signal in the
guide
and found that crispr transcription
could be enhanced by flipping two anu
nucleotides to prevent early termination
on top of that they additionally found
that by extending the length of the stem
loop guide stability was enhanced within
the cells
and interestingly there's actually a
cumulative effect of these two
improvements and that results in peak
crispr efficiency
so once again we wanted to perform our
own evaluation of the improved guide rna
scaffold using genes that we found to be
easy to knock down in several of our
cell lines so hei1 and ats1 on the right
and genes described to be difficult to
efficiently inhibit like calnexin on the
left
our results clearly show that the
improved guide rna enhances crispr
knockdown efficiency for nearly every
guide that we've tested
as i mentioned before crispr eye
technology has remained relatively
unchanged since its development in 2013
but a recent paper in nature methods
described a targeted approach to find
new crispr repressors
they identified mecp2 which is a
chromatin modifying gene involved in red
syndrome and they fused its
transcriptional repressor domain to
dcas9 crab
now although mecp2 isn't thought to
perform other cellular functions the
authors reported that it enhanced crispr
eye for hard to repress target genes
now we performed the trans sorry we can
we performed a comprehensive comparison
of all combinations of the guide
modifications
designs
and these competing as effectors however
our evaluation
did not identify any instances for
dozens of targets where the mecp2
construct was superior over crab dcas9
especially when combined with the
improved guide rna scaffold and alkyd
design already mentioned
an additional
improvement we used a dcas9 with an
n-terminal crab fusion that further
improves knockdown efficiency we also
incorporated a ucoe element in the
promoter to stabilize expression
for all of these reasons we developed
our crispr eye system and libraries
based on crab dcas9 and the improved
guide design and scaffold described by
the labs at ucsf
and because of this we remain confident
that our combination of crispr eye
components is really the best knockdown
system commercially available
to ensure that crispr is functioning
normally in your cell line we recommend
using our lenti grab one a positive
control rab 1a has a fairly uniform
expression reported across cell lines
from different tissue types as you can
see from the protein atlas expression at
the top
as well as
resulting in efficient knock down as you
can see on the bottom when we use
crisper eye
so why should you add crisper iron
christmas eye screening to your toolbox
crisper eye is complementary to existing
gain of function and loss of function
technologies
obviously the most comparison would be
with rnai
unlike rnai crispri does not compete for
any endogenous cellular machinery
by inhibiting gene function at the level
of transcription using crispr eye we can
observe increased knock-down efficiency
over rnai which has to keep disrupting
the translation of continuously dis
continuously transcribed mrna
they'll both achieve the same goal
and each can reveal novel information
but one of them is molecularly more
efficient which is the crispr eye we can
now also target non-coding rnas for
inhibition with more reliable loss of
function than possible with crispr
nucleases
and unlike crispr nucleases which need
to cut the dna and create function
breaking in dells crispr i can increase
the odds of disrupting gene expression
by only requiring binding of the complex
to each copy of the locus
and most importantly although crispr i
can yield up to 99 knock down efficiency
because it's still incomplete loss of
function you can still reveal essential
genes that would otherwise be overlooked
in a knockout screen
why should you use sigma aldridge crispr
iron agents well dks names use the crab
effect the domain mediates efficient
knockdown and although only a couple of
alternative effectors have been
described
crowd-based crispr eye continues to be a
well-published technology for single
targets and poor screening here are just
a handful of great papers that relied on
this technology and don't forget we've
actually moved the crab to the end
terminal
and that seems to work even better
along with the ukoi element that we
added
so why should you sorry um
i've gone back overnight one second
sorry there we go so we just recently
launched our whole genome crispr eye
libraries in march
but for those of you who want to explore
more focused corners of the genome this
is broken into individually available
sub libraries that are categorized into
functional groupings like the drug book
genome and non-coding genes so you have
both options
and of course we can customize
now these are highly functional guide
libraries we use them to perform an
enrichment screen
to implicate genes and pathways
responsible for resistance to drug
mediated cell death in human lung
adenocarcinoma cells using paclitaxel
and established chemistry
chemotherapeutic sorry
cells stably expressing crab dks9 were
transduced with lentiguide rnas from the
cancer and apoptosis subpool
and while our analysis using magic flute
identified anticipated genes like tp53
we also identified a novel role for nf2
or merlin in pax mediated cell death
so this data shows the utility of crispr
eye screening to identify new genes and
pathways involved in drug and disease
phenotypes
once again we've rounded out our new
pool libraries to include these two new
inhibition libraries the dolcetto
library is compact and efficient
allowing for more replicates or
screening without requiring more cells
or ngs for analysis
and then the crispr 10x crispr i10x
compatible library is derived from
draggable genome from the 2016 paper
published by the weizmann lab
the 10x compatibility stems from our
partnership with and collaboration with
the nxgenomics r d team showing that our
lentiviral vectors are highly compatible
with their feature barcode technology
okay now although i introduced crispurey
and chris pariah as standalone
technologies for screening their
complementarity allows for enrichment of
different gene sets for the same
phenotypes and for orthogonal validation
of important pathways
this is really a beautiful screen and it
was performed by luke gilbert and
colleagues to explore the gene pathways
that govern the sensitizing and
protective responses to a cholera
diphtheria toxin fusion
they capitalized on this orthogonal
validation strategy of pairing crispr
eye and crispry in parallel
they highlight the significance of
specific biosynthetic pathways that
modulate the sensitivity to this toxin
here you see gm1a which functions as a
receptor for this toxin knocking out the
enzyme that makes this ganglioside has a
non-protective effect on cells
using crispr i pulled screening
knockdown of enzymes in this
biosynthetic pathway
recapitulates this protective effect
using crispr-a as a complementary
screening approach revealed additional
biosynthetic pathways that confer this
protection
this results these sorry these results
highlight the capacity of crispr aid to
complement crispr eye by probing the
consequences of upregulating pathways
that might otherwise be inactive and
therefore missed by loss of function
screening
the complementary phenotypes observe so
the same targets screened using
crisprian crisp array illustrates the
strength of pairing these two screening
technologies and highlights the value of
orthogonal validation using both
one thing that's common about all of the
screens that i've talked about today is
the use of lentivirus as a delivery
platform for each of the crispr
components
so why would you use lentivirus or why
should you use length virus when
conducting crispr screens they're highly
efficient at delivering small to large
genetic payloads they're capable of
infecting dividing and non-dividing
cells they bypass the need to correctly
mix and pre-complex delivery agents like
if you're using rnp
and most importantly they allow stable
expression of crispr components
throughout the length of your experiment
now i did say i'd come back to this with
pull screening an important component of
the workflow is deconvolution so you can
actually get a readout of your hits we
can accept cell pellets after the screen
has been performed or if you'd rather do
the dna extraction yourself we can
accept dna pellets once we qc the dna we
perform deep sequencing of the samples
and provide you with easy to analyze
data showing each gene target and the
counts associated with those targets
the nice thing about this is that we can
bundle in the deconvolution at the time
of purchase of the pools which leaves
the package as being a highly cost
effective end-to-end solution for a
pooled screening project
so we can do the deconvolution for you
finally we've been talking about using
these large format screens to narrow
down a list of relevant gene candidates
but to take a deeper functional genomics
dive we can now combine crispr screening
with single cell analysis
so we've partnered with 10x genomics to
develop compatible reagents for crispr
and crispr eye that allow for individual
targets or custom pools to explore the
transcriptional changes in single cells
for a more in-depth molecular analysis
our 10x compatible vectors contain one
of four different 10x feature barcoding
capture motifs which you can see here on
the left to facilitate guide
identification in each cell you can see
that we have capture sequence one and
capture sequence two and then we have
two versions of each so one where the uh
capture sequence is uh sorry the the bar
chord is on the um on the stem loop on
the three prime end and then on the
right you can see knock down efficiency
across the different capture sequences
for our recommended crispr i positive
control guides by qpcr
and you can see a very nice knock down
because we've observed differences in
capture sequence for each capture
sequence between different cell lines we
have created an optimization kit with
controls containing each of these
capture sequences and that should allow
you to determine which is the best
capture strategy for your cell line and
experiments
so using the loop cell browser in cell
ranger from 10x we can visualize each
cell represented by a single dot in one
of these experiments
on the left is a umaf projection of gene
expression based clustering and on the
right
cells are clustered based on guide
identity and are clearly distinguishable
using those colors and looking back to
the plot on the left we can see that
there are no major clustering
differences between our rep 1a control
guide versus the non-targeting guide
based on global expression profiles
analyzing target gene expression based
on guide identity we can see a
significant reduction of rab1a mrna in
cells that receive the rab1a crispr eye
guide versus the non-targeting guide
this work was done in collaboration with
r d over at 10x genomics
we also needed to make sure that no
combination of capture sequence and
location disrupts global transcriptional
profiling in cells so cells containing
guides with each of the four capture
motifs separately can be completely
overlaid and do not segregate
independently as you can see here
measuring guide efficiency rab1a
expression across all guide formats
shows similar and significant knockdown
we also made sure that no combination of
capture sequence and location disrupts
i just talked about that one second
sorry there we go we then tested our
compatible vectors in a pooled format of
about a hundred guides on the left we
can see clustering based on global gene
expression profiling
on the right we can see distinct
clustering based on crispr guide
identification showing that this
platform
is capable of identifying unique guides
in a pool and allows exploration of gene
expression in a single cell as a
consequence of a specific crispr guide
let's focus in on cells containing one
of those crispr eye guides targeting
elof 1 versus non-targeting control
guide
we can see significant knockdown of
eloph1 that correlates with guide
identity
and if we look at global transcriptional
changes between these two populations of
cells we can highlight those genes that
are downloaded down regulated in the
experimental cells
and those that are upregulated relative
to cells with the non-targeting control
guide
single cell analysis with our 10x
compatible crispr vectors therefore is a
great way to probe the functional
consequences of target gene modulation
with crispr
and present an ideal opportunity to
follow up on top hits from a pooled
crisper screen with a single cell
rna-seq using small poles of guides
to finish off i have mentioned several
times the new pools library was launched
and they have all they are all libraries
that have been published so here is a
slide showing the publications that they
come from
with that i would like to thank you very
much for your time and i will take any
questions but i will leave it on the
previous slide so you can have a look at
those publications again
thank you capri for your informative
presentation we will now start the q a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
let's get started
our first question is do you have bench
protocols for screening with each of
these platforms
yeah we do we have extensive protocols
on our website and they're easy enough
to find um
and of course if there's anything
that you have additional questions on
you can always contact us and we have
we have
extensive knowledge in the in the
company to help you
thank you for that our next question
is can crispr a and crisper eye be used
in the same cells at the same time
um
so at the moment i would say with the
existing technology and the fact that
you have different cast nines um
or cast nines with with modifications on
them to do crispr and crispr eye i think
the technology with the existing
technology that's that's not going to be
efficient
so i would say at the moment uh no you'd
have to do them side by side but you
can't do them at the same time in the
same cells
okay
and then for we have another really good
question coming in
can these screens be done in primary
cells or only in immortalized lines
so we we've done we've done a lot of
work in immortalized lines um but i know
there are publications out there
especially from i think alex martin
using primary cells i believe it can be
done um
there are additional considerations to
take into account you know some cells
may be resistant to uh
to some of the technologies like crispr
prior crispr a um but no you should be
able to uh to to use both types of cells
thank you for that
so our next question
can these libraries be edited or
modified
um
so um if you buy the off-the-shelf
versions of this then no but you know as
as i went through the presentation
several times i mentioned custom
um so we can pretty much customize
anything so if you wanted your own
guides um in
any of the vectors that we already have
or even if you have um some vectors of
your own we can actually do that there's
a little bit more work to be done there
we have to
do
but we can um we can pretty much
customize anything but if you bought one
of the off-the-shelf um
lines one of the off-the-shelf libraries
then no those can't be edited or
modified
and we do sell the final product right
so we um already um do the cloning in
for you and and what we provide is is
ready to use so you can't take one that
we already have and then modify it
yourself
okay
thank you for that it looks like we have
time for
one more question
do we have products for crisper eye or a
to generate aav or in viva research in
mice
so i i'm i'm not sure right so yes we do
have obviously have products for chris
barai but they're all in lentivirus
we don't have any um any
aav
based
crispr eye products
but if there is
there is an interest there's always
things that we're willing to discuss
but no we don't have anything off the
shelf or anything that we've done
recently to my knowledge i do have one
of the product managers
um on here with me maybe he can he can
add in but as far as i know um we
haven't done any aaa he works
um but yes all of our crispr eye
reagents are in lentivirus
yeah this is casey i'm one of the genome
imaging modulation
product managers um we don't currently
offer anything in aav as you know um
crisper eye
with all the the the size is is rate
limiting in terms of these products um
but certainly we can um discuss on a
custom basis as g
compre mentioned earlier
we can certainly do this on and discuss
on a custom basis
all right thank you casey and caprice do
you have any final comments for our
audience
uh no i mean
so we've we've obviously recently
expanded the um
the libraries that we have there's
obviously other products that we haven't
talked about today our portfolios is is
very broad uh we have rnp's um
uh obviously today we didn't talk about
the shrna or the oauths but there are
other products and then in terms of our
crispr portfolio we've just enhanced
that with the new pools libraries that
that we um that we've launched we've
already had a lot of interest in those
um
so anybody who is interested in any of
those types of reagents whether it's
pools whether it's
a raid whether it's individual um
different formats of of guide rnas or
shrnaws please do get in touch with us
as i said at the start we have a a long
history in this area and unparalleled
expertise so
don't be afraid to contact us for any
questions
that do come up afterwards and thank you
for listening
thank you again for your time today and
your important research before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today for
and for all their interesting questions
i'd also like to thank our sponsor
milipor sigma for sponsoring today's
webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until september 29th of 2023
labyrinths will alert you via email and
is available for replay we encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
and until next time
goodbye